ya que tenemos un simulador de resortes
vamos a abordar un problema que
encontramos en la primera lección
anteriormente tratamos de usar solo
resortes para modelar nuestros mechones
de cabello eso resultó en un cabello que
rebotaba mucho divertido sí pero no muy
realista para abordar esto le agregamos
un amortiguador a cada resorte recuerda
los amortiguadores se resisten a los
cambios en la velocidad provocando que
nuestros resortes lleguen a estar en
reposo más rápido de manera matemática
un amortiguador es bastante sencillo
podemos pensar que el amortiguador es
una nueva fuerza que actúa en la
dirección opuesta a la dirección de la
primera fuerza del resorte el tamaño de
esta fuerza va a depender de dos cosas
primero que tan fuerte es el
amortiguador a esto lo llamaremos el
coeficiente de amortiguamiento segundo
la velocidad del desplazamiento del
resorte si el resorte se está estirando
o comprimiendo muy rápido
la fuerza del amortiguamiento será
grande y si el resorte no se está
moviendo no hay fuerza de
amortiguamiento ya que no hay movimiento
al cual resistirse podemos usar una
ecuación muy sencilla para describir
esta situación la fuerza
de amortiguamiento es igual al
coeficiente de amortiguamiento
multiplicado por la velocidad de la
partícula muy bien vamos a agregar esta
nueva fuerza a nuestro sistema en la
parte superior de nuestro programa
necesitamos inicializar una nueva
variable que se llame de ping
amortiguamiento en inglés anteriormente
a esto lo llamamos el coeficiente de
amortiguamiento cero significa que no
hay amortiguamiento y mientras más alto
sea el número más intenso es el
amortiguador ahora podemos pasar a la
función de dibujo draw y definir esta
nueva fuerza de amortiguamiento justo
abajo del cálculo de nuestra fuerza del
resorte spring force guay voy a definir
una nueva variable que se llama de ping
force guay fuerza amortiguamiento y en
inglés y va a ser igual al
amortiguamiento multiplicado por la
velocidad y esto es de ping force guay
igualad en ping por velocity white a
continuación agregamos esta fuerza a
nuestro cálculo force white por ahora
sólo estamos tomando en cuenta la
gravedad y la fuerza del resorte
así que necesitamos restar nuestra
fuerza de amortiguamiento puesto que se
resiste a la fuerza del resorte muy bien
vamos a intentarlo aquí está la
respuesta sin amortiguamiento a este
sistema lo llamamos suba amortiguado ya
que rebota siempre vamos a intentar
aumentar nuestra variable de
amortiguamiento a uno observa que llega
a estar en reposo más rápido esto está
mejorando pero si hago que la variable
de amortiguamiento del pin sea igual
algo muy grande como 100 entonces
tenemos problemas esto se llama sobre
amortiguamiento el resorte casi no se
mueve esto no es realista el truco es
encontrar el balance adecuado entre la
rigidez del resorte y el amortiguamiento
para obtener movimiento realista vamos a
pausar aquí para que puedas probar esto
por tu cuenta
intenta experimentar con los
coeficientes de amortiguamiento y de la
fuerza del resorte para obtener un
comportamiento realista buena suerte